das thema wo können sie wog definieren
wenn ich höre denke ich mal lockt also
das ist das instrument mit dem man
wunderbar kochen kann aber wo ist
offensichtlich eine bewegung die glaubt
dass sie durch sprache die
disziplinierung für die
gesellschaftliche fortschritt
herbeiführen kann bei uns würde niemand
so anfangen zu reden aber wenn er so
reden würde würden wir es uns erstmal
die frage stellt verstehen wir ihnen
wissen wir was er meine sprache ist ein
kommunikationsmittel
und dann würden wir sie akzeptieren
jeder soll so reden wie er glaubt dass
es richtig ist man bei manchen gefühl
wenn ich das im fernsehen sehe ist eine
sprachstörung aber daran kann ich mich
gewöhnen wie gesagt nein er ist nicht
vorgeschrieben wird dass ich so reden
muss mir jetzt banane es gab ja sowie
ansätze über hochschulen und schulen wo
arbeiten die mich länder gerecht
geschrieben worden sind anders bewertet
worden sind das dankenswerterweise von
der rechtsprechung gekippt worden noch
einmal ich warne dringend davor zu
glauben man könnte durch diese form der
sprache die neugestaltung menschen
menschen erziehen wenn menschen glauben
sie sollten zu reden ist mir egal
solange ich versteh ich nicht weiß was
sie meinen ist mir sicher hat es
deutschland verändert das 16 jahre eine
frau kanzlerin war
nein sagt deutschland verändert dass in
den 16 jahren
die kanzlerin es geschafft in 1 zu
erwecken als legales bei ihren guten
händen und wir heute feststellen dass
wir 16 jahre nicht ausschließlich aber
überwiegend viele sachen verschlafen
waren die merkel ruhe hat uns nicht gut
getan wir sind im digitalen bereich
mittlerweile so weit nach hinten
durchgereicht worden dass es schwer
werden würde das in den nächsten jahren
wirklich aufzuholen mit großer
geschwindigkeit wir sind von 20 staaten
wo jetzt die auf platz 17 wir sind in
europa auf platz neun muss jetzt mal
vorstellen
das noch überholt und auch bei den
zukunftsfragen nicht klimawandel und
-bewältigung war die politik der
kanzlerin seit 2002 immer darauf
ausgerichtet zu beruhigen stadt
anzuschauen was war für sie die debatte
wo sie sich geärgert haben
die meinungsfreiheit ist debatte ich
ärgere mich darüber dass das war
aufgenommen worden ist auch von großen
publikationsorgan zeit spiegelbild ja
ohnehin wir haben ein demokratieproblem
wenn zwei drittel der menschen glauben
sie könnten ihre meinung nicht mehr frei
äußern das bundesverfassungsgerichts
seien regelmäßig die meinungsfreiheit
ist eine der tragenden säulen eines
demokratischen gemeinwesens und darüber
müssen wir als politische
entscheidungsträger uns wirklich
gedanken machen wir empfinden wir
bekommen ja auch nicht mehr mit richtig
mit was in der bevölkerung passiert wenn
menschen das gefühl dann ich äußere mich
einfach nicht mehr was sind noch
klartext themen die sie in hier in der
im restaurant oder in der bar in der
kneipe in strande wahrnehmen die zu
wenig eine rolle spielte war kann
die kasse an dass die meisten menschen
das gefühl dass durch für 100 pandemie
maßnahme sie über gebühren in ihren
grund und freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt
worden sind wir befolgen das was
sinnvoll ist was er nachvollziehen
können aber unsinnige maßnahmen nicht
wir haben ja deutschland auch die
erklärung wir hatten niemals darf mehr
als eine etwa so was einem anderen
haushalt empfangen und gleichzeitig weil
es ja alle wollten bundesweit war wie
gesagt es wird nicht kontrolliert wie
ein wein ist das ein ehepaar mit denen
sie lange gefroren jetzt etwas gegenüber
wohnt zu trennen zwei stunden manchmal
stand die ehefrau die hat kein mensch
hat sich daran gehalten ist verständlich
haben sich die paare auch weiter
getroffen wie vorher aus und haben sie
keine sorge dass da irgend jemand
vorbeikommt ein foto macht und das
online stellt und sagt irgendwie mensch
da sitzt jetzt der kubicki in der kneipe
das darf man doch gar nicht dass das
verboten wie gut der die ein foto machen
können die werthaltig reingekommen ist
freundlich zu formulieren und wenn
jemand fotografiert von von meinem
nachbarn kubicki trifft sich mit einem
weiteren pärchen die gegner gut
einsammeln 22 50 euro bußgeld aber es
hätte ich mich nie davon abgehalten
meine nachbarn zu trennen oder meine
freunde zu trennen bevor wir vorne ehe
brand zu tun haben wir nie daran hab gar
nicht meine kinder sind zu trennen wenn
sie mich besucht das heißt sie sind in
der regel meinen einwand dass die virus
völlig geheilt ist die beiden leben
zusammen wir leben zusammen auch wenn
wir uns getrennt hätten wir es den
bewusst wenn es denn da gewesene völlig
egal also diese unsinnigen maßnahmen
davon gab es eine reihe die haben dazu
geführt dass auch sehr viel verdruss
entstanden ist wenn man sich das besser
überlegt und nicht nicht versucht zu
dokumentieren dass er starten macht hat
ihn zwar etwas anzuordnen ohne es
durchsetzen zu können dann wäre glaube
ich eine viel grössere zustimmung aus
zudem pandemie maßnahmen erfolgt also
ist der fall gewesen ich akzeptiere dass
wir noch viel lieber ist seit gestern
vornehmen aber sie führen bei uns wenn
sie
in die wunde rhinow arena gegen zum
handballspiel
thw ging ist wie vielleicht ja welche
handewitt dann können sie da reingehen
ohne masken können die miranda sitzen
können wieder bier trinken und alles
mögliche sie müssen eben nur nachweisen
die hierauf sind die ebenso getestet hat
sich hier reinkam die das lokal hat
keiner gesagt machen sie mal luca
kontakt nach wie vor weil es keins wir
müssen das nicht mehr tun die hat keiner
gesagt setzen sie bitte mal die maske
auf sie würden hier sogar strich
angeguckt werden wenn sie die maske
aufsetzen weil wir das gefühl hatten sie
seien vielleicht infiziert und müssten
sie dass er uns alle schützen also noch
einmal der weg in die freiheit ist
geebnet und je schneller wäre ein
schlechterer scheint modell bundesweit
folgen nicht den bayerischen mit der
hohen instituts werden den hohen
todesfalls seien desto mehr haben die
leute wieder drauf dass sie findet sich
selbst so müssen dass sie
eigenverantwortlich und für ihre
gesundheit und dass die normalität
nichts böses ist wovor sie angst haben
müssen nun etwas gut ist weil es gut
macht auch wieder zu leben es gibt
masten schlecht es gibt immer noch kein
ende in sicht es gibt weiterhin
beschränkungen
wann hat das ein ende
es könnte eigentlich schon zu ende sein
weil ja das infektionsschutzgesetz davon
ausgeht die grundlegende maßnahmen
treffen wir um eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern die
steht gar nicht mehr im raum
und es hat ja in den letzten monaten
immer wieder neue erklärung gegeben
warum die maßnahme ich aufgelöst werden
können ernst war es die älteren die sind
alle bis zu 90 prozent geimpft da kann
ich mir viel passieren dann war es die
möglichkeit dass nicht alle angebot
bekommen hatten das haben sie
mittlerweile auch die ihr leben hat ja
bis juli noch erklärt wenn alle an dem
angebot bekommen haben also alle
erwachsenen dann gibt es keine
rechtliche grundlage mehr für die
aufrechterhaltung der maßnahmen jetzt
auch wieder verschoben worden unsere
dänische frauen dann ganz anders
reagiert sie haben alle maßnahmen
aufgelöst nachdem klar war alle über 60
jährigen sind ordentlich geimpft worden
für den rest ist es unproblematisch 100
system und deshalb tun wir alles wieder
öffnen
ich glaube das wird nicht mehr sehr
lange dauern weil nicht nur incidents
zahlen sehen wir sind ja hier sind ja
nicht mehr viele bälle und steht
unmittelbar bevor schleswig-holstein
dokumentiert wie man es machen können
wir haben hier die dreijährige gewalt
dort wo sie teddy haben brauchen sie
keinen kontakt nach verfolgung mehr kann
den masken mehr zu tragen kann abstand
mehr zu halten warum infektionsschutz
ist gefahrenabwehr aber nicht
durchgelesen geimpft oder getestet
nachweise von michael keine gefahr aus
gibt es auch keine rechtliche grundlage
mehr an die maßnahmen werden sie kommen
ohne zu einer bedingung also dem freedom
day der freiheit das ist die
freiheitsrechte komplett zurückkehren
zur bedingung machen die
koalitionsgespräche mit dem noch immer
kann zunächst einmal ist der
freiheitsstatue 26 19 da können die
menschen wählen beispielsweise freie
demokraten um der versorgung zu tragen
dass wir schnellstmöglich einen normalen
verfassungsmäßigen zustand zurückkehren
es wird keine bedingung sein wir werden
massiv dafür kämpfen das haben wir auch
schon im deutschen bundestag gemacht die
pandemische lagen maximalbetrag weiter
aufzuheben die rechtliche basis macht
dies zur bedingung gehen sie da rein und
sagen oder fritz mensch also erstmal
entweder weil ihr mit uns sprechen
wollte
wir werden sagen wir werden keine
maßnahmen mehr mittragen auch in der
koalition nicht die wir für
unverhältnismäßig hätten bei mehreren
papieren mehreren entschließungsanträgen
des deutschen bundestages dokumentiert
was wir was wir glauben und ich vermute
mal dass das problem bis wir eine
koalition haben sich ohnehin gelöst
haben werden weil sogar lautern war sich
das sicherlich anders da spricht ja
schon vor dem gefährlichen herbst und
der gesundheitsminister werden machen
sie zur bedingung dass kann also ich
schätze den kollegen karl lauterbach
sehr wir haben in dem der pandemie frage
er aus medizinischer sicht aus
juristischer sicht in weiten teilen
völlig unterschiedliche auffassungen
trotzdem sondern einer der wenigen mit
die mir wirklich intensiv darüber
diskutieren können ich bin auch ganz
begeistert wenn er immer sagt ja gerade
noch mal eine neue studie gelesen werden
ich würde mir abends was anderes
vorstellen als nur studien zu lesen aber
sie reagieren die leute hier in der
stammkneipe auf karl lauterbach bei
ihnen nicht nicht positiv was sagen
diese
also man würde ihn morgen so sagen die
spacken oder dumpfbacke
das sagen sie ja nicht nur hier sondern
das weiß kann ob er war auch also auch
die malocher aus dem aus leverkusen und
bochum da wo er kandidiert sie sagen das
ist keine von uns der wilde dürfen die
krähen wir dürfen nichts fußballstadion
energie länder aber natürlich darf und
wie gesagt er ist ein mensch mit dem man
wirklich gut das tut gut diskutieren
können was ich ja als vertreter der
meinungsfreiheit auch region finden ist
wenn sie sich in der sache streiten sich
persönlich zu sehen die wäsche zu gehen
das ist unterentwickelt bei uns in
deutschland alle kann aber das tor
als armin laschet persönlich wird
schweren die tatsache dass das gerade
die csu bis gestern noch knüppel
zwischen die geschmissen hat ist für die
union eine katastrophe ein solches maß
an illoyalität wie von söder oder blume
habe ich meine politischen leben ich bin
50 jahren ist dabei noch nicht erlebt
also wenn eine flasche sagt selbst der
zweite hatte eine chance mehr dem
deutschen bundestag zu leben und am
selben derselben sekunde sagt markus
wieder nein entweder nummer eins der
opposition ist das eben keine
unterstützung des kandidaten
also erstens ich sie müssen sich schon
wir sind auf oder scholz jetzt
einstellen ich stelle mich nach wie vor
darauf einen der stadt möglich ist und
wir werden alles versuchen dass auch in
sachsen setzen wie gesagt wir möchten
schon eine wunderbare blaupause dass
damit gute politik gemacht werden kann
auch wenn berlin haben was anderes ist
als ein land aber
wir sind auf alles vorbereitet die
freien demokraten nicht das einzige was
wir sagen wie wir menschen können sich
darauf verlassen dass die zusagen die
wir in dem auch eingehalten werden sind
niemand sollte uns zu gesprächen
einladen der mit uns über
steuererhöhungen reden
[Musik]